[Music]
uh
we're home hey hi what's up little guy
how you doing how you doing how's your
day
getting poor daddy why don't we have
a pool
nice
that's a good question son
um we're gonna get one really soon okay
where did he get that how should i know
he's a child
you know what i know where he learned he
learned it because you're teaching him
that crap because you're out of control
spending that's what he learned
clark sweetie you're overreacting it was
an innocent cause
i'm overreacting no no no no innocence
stems from ignorance he's not ignorant
laura
our son is not ignorant he knows full
well what's going on
he knows we can afford certain luxuries
right now we can't afford a pool
don't let this get to you please
[Music]
it's gonna get better you need to
believe in yourself
i made this for you daddy well i'm
getting ready for meeting now son
all right let daddy finish here i'll
check it out later
all right run along bud go ahead
from the moment we're born life changes
pretty quickly we go through several
different phases of our life
there was a time when our biggest
concern was making friends at school
how hard that was getting bullied or
picked on trying to fit in
be part of the cool crowd
remember when you first got your
driver's license you went to the movies
by yourself and nobody dropped you off
how about the first speeding ticket
remember your girlfriend your first love
you went on your first date where your
mom didn't have to accompany you and
embarrass you from the girl you're
trying to impress
remember that warm fuzzy feeling
of laughing together maybe even staying
up for a few hours
and you may not want to admit it but i
think we all had that one
six hour conversation with a special
someone
remember graduation celebrating with
your friends
how many of them are still your friends
how time flies
then the bigger decisions start
occurring do i go to college
do i get a job
the real world beckons and you start
your first day of work
you and the lady are getting serious you
propose you get married
[Music]
maybe buy your first home and you think
you're living the american dream
the place where you're working at it's
starting to feel like home
maybe you feel the sense of
accomplishment by getting promoted and
getting a raise
and the time came when you and your
spouse decided to start a family
but maybe your first attempt took a turn
for the worse
[Music]
must unlearn the misconception that the
world has conditioned
us to believe patrick i thought about
what you said last time we spoke
i have worked hard my whole life
and i'm not satisfied i don't know why
but
i just i feel like there's got to be
something more to light
clark i i totally understand your
frustration i think most of us
go through that level at some point of
our lives
but quite frankly i don't know what
phase your life you're currently in
maybe you're at a place where you're
part of an industry where you're
experiencing too many lows and not
enough highs
you know maybe you feel like you're at a
place where you've been waiting for
promotion for a while and you haven't
experienced it
maybe the bank account isn't where you
want it to be maybe you start to realize
life is pretty expensive
and uh maybe you're at a point where you
need a secondary income or
even you feel like your talents are not
being used you see clark
i don't know where you're at you know
what i do know
i do know many years ago man sat with me
just like this
and had a conversation with me and he
challenged me and he changed my life
and that could be me in your life right
now let me share with you my story
because i'll never forget june 3rd 1989
when khamenei died
i was living in iran one of the scariest
days of my life
i'll never forget that day i was only a
boy but the streets were flooded with
mourners and
eight people were trampled that day
regime change can always be difficult
and we knew the timing was not to make a
move
we fled six weeks later i remember
clearly being on the lufthansa flight
and we didn't fully feel free until we
crossed the border and heard the magical
words
you can officially order alcohol later
on we lived in a refugee camp for a year
and a half in air long in germany
my parents got a divorce because of the
move they obviously sacrificed
everything to bring us here for the
opportunity
we came to the states on november 28
1990.
it almost didn't seem real because it
was always a dream of ours to come to
america
i'll never forget watching movies like
rocky gremlins and ghostbusters and
telling ourselves what if one day we get
to come to america
and that actually became a reality so i
went to school and excelled at being a
below average student
and after high school the army became my
choice hoping to find myself there
i ended up being stationed at the 101st
airborne division in fort campbell
kentucky
after serving a few years in the
military when i got out i still didn't
know what industry i wanted to get
involved in as a career
i'll never forget a conversation i had
with a very successful businessman in
newport beach
who owned his own yacht company willing
to give me some direction on my next
move
he asked me patrick do you like sports
i'm a big sports guy
he says what are the richest sports in
america
right now i play baseball and i play
basketball i said baseball and
basketball
he said baseball and basketball are the
poor man sport
i was so offended by that but i wanted
to know what his explanation was so why
is it the poor man's sport
he said you know what kind of companies
advertising baseball and basketball
games
i said tell me he said beer coca-cola
nike and mcdonald's he says you know who
buys those four things i said who
he said poor people he said that's why
you're poor they're marketing to you i
couldn't believe what he said but it
made sense
he said the richest sports in america
are golf and tennis
he said you know sponsors golf and
tennis tournaments i said who
he said financial firms and insurance
companies such as ing
allianz hartford allstate prudential
chase pacific life do you know why
i said why he said because the wealthy
understand how money works
the rest don't before it's too late go
learn how money works and get involved
in the financial industry
and that's exactly what i did that's
when i decided to get involved with
morgan stanley dean witter on 9
10 2001 which was a day before 9 11.
i'll never forget that day it was
probably the worst
time to get involved in the financial
industry and as i got involved with them
you know i realized they tailored more
to people who had money wasn't for
everybody in middle america
and i really came from middle income
family myself so i wanted to be able to
help them out as much as i could
so i left morgan stanley and i went to
aegon which they focused a little bit
more on middle-income families and i
became a broker with them
i had a chance to meet a lot of great
people travel the world
life was pretty good until 2008
2008 was one of those years where i sat
down and started questioning some things
in my life
now that i reached a certain level of
success what is life all about now
so in 2009 i had dinner with george will
and pat boone at the miramar hotel in
santa monica
never forget that day and what took
place in my life
i went there wanting to find something
that could hopefully catch my heart
something that could really light up
fire my heart right
and i heard george will speak about
america talking about the american dream
and obviously i relate as an immigrant
coming to you from
iran and i will tell you having lived in
many different places in the world
there's only one dream i've ever heard
of
i've never heard of the iranian dream
i've never heard of the iraqi dream
i've never heard about the serbian dream
i've only heard one dream and that is
the american dream
that is why america leads all countries
in the world for attracting the most
immigrants who want to come here why you
see in iran
we didn't have a lot of freedoms i can
go around telling everybody about my
religion
i couldn't go and speak with other
people about things i disagreed with
what if i didn't agree with what the
president said i couldn't say anything
i can go out there and make as much
money as i wanted
but in america i have all of these
different freedoms
but i noticed challenge taking place in
america
started asking myself are we still the
united states of america are we becoming
the divided states of america
i see too many people arguing with each
other right
from the outside america looks so pretty
but on the inside
democrats were fighting with republicans
and those that didn't want to fight
became independent or libertarians
i started seeing church people having
challenges with people who didn't want
to go to church
as if they had become enemies and it
started really being very
important to me where i wanted to do
something about it patrick let me tell
you how i was raised you know
my parents believe you have to be very
very careful where you place your trust
and i believe the biggest challenge
facing america these days is trust
it's exactly that right we don't trust
the government
we don't trust political leaders on both
sides we don't trust the system that's
for sure
we've been taught not to trust uh the
stock market
and truth be told why should i even
trust you clark you don't have to that's
a choice
i want you to know that we're all
skeptical everybody is skeptical because
we've all been taken advantage of at
some point of our lives
and uh most of us have been raised with
our parents that taught us to say no you
know don't
trust anybody and don't talk to
strangers and that conditioning
led us to wanting to follow a certain
set of rules and system go to school
get a job work for that company you know
get that pension plan that everything is
going to work out for you but
clark that's pre-9 11 thinking the the
world has changed the system's been
altered
us playing it safe has cost people
ever fully known their potential and
clark that's why
we need to unlearn a lot of those things
we've been taught throughout our lives
and one of the areas we need to unlearn
is regarding money
think about it we go to elementary
school we go to high school we go to
college
how many classes are we taught on the
basics of money none
how much do we learn about how money
works nothing and that reminds me of
what happened on 9 11. i think we could
both agree today that we will never
forget it changed
america forever to come obviously there
was a lot of
devastation we had with losing our
towers but what i think about
more i think about the family
that woke up in the morning husband and
wife they have a kid there
and the husband's working in the world
trade center
do you think he knew that that morning
was going to be the last day he was
going to hug his child
no way in the world nowhere in the world
no
he goes to work last day
loses his life how the wife was affected
by them
how the kids were affected by that as
the breath winner
what is she going to be doing how does
she explain that to the kids 15
16 years later who's she going to be
moving in with
she doesn't have a job these are real
stories
these are things that took place and
unfortunately some of these events are
unavoidable
clark i think in every family someone
needs to take charge and have the
finances in order i'm talking about
making sure savings in place for
emergency college education for the kids
retirement planning life insurance
someone needs to do that
and i think for the most part we want to
know that we've taken care of our
families
right i think about the scene with safe
and private ryan if remember at the end
of the movie when they're in the
cemetery and
it's the matt damon all the version of
matt damon is speaking to his wife and
he says
tell me i've lived a good life tell me
i've been a good man
right i think most of us would like to
hear that from our spouse
at some point of our life i'm one of
those people clark i am as well
everybody would like to hear that
so what's holding people back what's
holding most people back is simply fear
clark think about it
most people are afraid of doing
something new
most people are afraid of risk most
people are afraid of change
most people are afraid of not pleasing
everybody why do you think most people
are not financially free
there's a reason for that you know i
think about
timing being one of them most people
could be at the right place in the right
time and do nothing about it
what do you mean by that think about 76
million
babies being born between 1946
and 1964. and imagine if this generation
was able to dictate
what industry was going to forge over
the next 40 50 60 years
if you look at in the 40s what do
newborn babies need they need baby food
they need diapers they need toys
that industry took off in the 50s these
kids are 5 6 7 years old they need to
attend school
construction took off to build schools
in the 60s they're turning 16 years old
what's the first thing on their mind
they want a car sports cars took off
70s 80s they're turning 30 years old
they want to build a family
they want to buy a home real estate took
off and today
these babies are no longer babies
they're roughly in their late 40s
to mid to late 60s what do you think
they're thinking about you're probably
thinking about retirement that's exactly
what they're thinking about they're
thinking about retirement a matter of
fact according to boston college
there is roughly going to be 41 trillion
to 136 trillion dollars being
transferred from the boomer's hand
to the next and that represents
a very big opportunity for millennials
where a lot of millennials are looking
at the same wait a minute maybe i can do
something with this maybe there's an
industry i should get involved in
because
the average age of an agent today in the
financial industry
is 57 year old white male 57
57 years old and how long do you think
this
agent is planning on staying in the
industry at that age probably not long i
mean they're pretty set in their ways
but i'm sure they wouldn't want to stand
very much longer so in essence the way
the millennials are taking a look at
this is that
not only can they get involved in the
financial industry for them to learn
how to get their own finances in order
but also at the same time when you're
talking about 41 to 136 trillion dollars
that represents a big opportunity for
them to make money and become
financially free
while servicing the baby boomers
unfortunately
majority of us are governed by our fears
and it's this fear
that prevents them from taking action in
their lives
fear really you have nothing to fear if
you just stick to what you know best and
you don't deviate from the plan right
has that way of thinking work for you
probably not and neither did it work for
me for many years i used to think that
way as well until i realized
if things are not going the way i want
it to be maybe i need to change my way
of thinking
i never thought of it that way you're
telling me to unlearn some of the things
that may be who i am today
anybody that did anything big with their
lives
they had somebody in their lives that
not only believed in them
but also someone that challenged their
way of thinking
and any time our way of thinking is
challenged
we replace our old way of thinking with
a what a new way of thinking right
and once that happens we start walking
different
we talk different we think different
we perform in a whole different way
which leads to new results
new experiences new things in life
so you're talking about new lifestyle
better relationships
better business life better finance life
better health
so in essence it leads to you
potentially buying that house that you
always wanted to live in in that gated
community
you've been able to take your wife to
the place you've been promising her to
go to
maybe it's tuscany maybe it's sydney
australia maybe it's tahiti
and she is wanting to go to this place
about 10 15 years it's never happened
and you get a chance to take those dream
trips together with your wife and kids
i mean why not you get a chance to
replace that 10 year old car you're
driving with a 20 year old car you're
driving that keeps breaking
down and now you're replacing it with a
new car every three years where you're
listening you don't have to worry about
the car breaking down maybe your kid's
going to that private school that costs
a month you don't need to worry about
that anymore because now you can't
afford it
life changes savings increases
we're more at peace we start really
experiencing what it is to control
our own life to experience freedom i
mean that's really what we're looking
for
but when it comes down to it
clark you're going to need to make that
decision because the choice is going to
be on you
i think what it'll come down to is what
your reason would be your motivation
would be
to make the next move if that
[Music]
opportunity
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
you